opening track come together is as iconic  as the album cover itself as of August  2014 Abbey Road remains the Beatles  best-selling album 45 years ago  photographer in villain climbed a ladder  in the middle of Abbey Road in London  outside the legendary music studio the  band recorded at in 10 minutes he took  six photos of the Fab Four the fit of  those shots would become the album cover  and one of pop music's most famous  images now rare outtakes and the final  cover shot will be available at auction  if believed to be the first time that a  complete set of the signed and numbered  photos has ever been offered this slice  of memorabilia is expected to sell for  up to $100,000